اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم اقدم اليكم هذه المقابله الخاصه من
اسطنبول مع
القيادي في حزب الشعب الجمهوري اهلا بكم
معنا سيد سكين في هذه المقابله الخاصه على
شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم وانا اشكركم اهلا وسهلا بكم ايضا
في تركيا يوصف تحالفكم بالاستثناء هذه
المره ولكن بالخطير ايضا على ذاته قبل ان
يكون على حزب العداله والتنميه وعلى
السلطه في تركيا لانه يضم توجهات متناقضه
الى حد بعيد
محافظين مع اقوى كرديه رئيسيه في البلد
كانت على عداء مستحكم معكم اضافه الى
الخلافات التي كانت مستشريه في داخل
التحالف هل كان تحالف الضروره فقط لاسقاط
اردوغانشو يعني
سببه كالتالي طبعا في الفترات السابقه لم
يكن هذا النظام وكانت الاحزاب السياسيه
تخوض الانتخابات منفرده بشكل طبيعي لكن
هذا النظام رفع السقف الانتخابي الى 50
زائد واحد ما ولد ضروره التوحد عده احزاب
سياسيه تحت تحالف واحد وهذا ليس بحقنا فقط
بل في الطرف الاخر ايضا فعندما ننظر الى
تحالف الجمهور نجدهم يتشكلون من حزب
العداله والتنميه والحركه القوميه وحزب
الله ودوجو برنجك وما الى ذلك من الاحزاب
وما تحالفنا نحن الا الاسقاط هذا النظام
وليس للانتصار على اردوغان فقط بل لتغيير
نظامه هذا ايضا
ولكن الى اي مدى انتم واثقون من ان
القاعده الانتخابيه القاعده الشعبيه لكم
ستقبل بمثل هذه التحالفات البعض يقول بانه
جزء من هذه القاعده قد تضطر الى اعطاء
صوتها لاخرين او عدم اعطاء صوتها بسبب هذه
التحالفات المتناقضه تبي
[موسيقى]
طبعا لا يمكن معرفه نتائج الاقتراع من
الان غير انني في الوقت ذاته رجل الميدان
اعرفه جيدا ما يجعلني ارى امكانيه ان يمنح
المحافظون والاكراد والعرب وعناصر سياسيه
كثيره اصواتهم للسيد كرشدار اوغلو واراه
يتصدر منافسي في ظل هذه الظروف
[موسيقى]
بما انك قلت انك شخص ميداني ونائب حالي في
هذه الدوره ما هي حساباتكم لنتائج
الرئاسيات وكذلك البرلمانيات
ها هنا ارى امرين مختلفين جدا الاول
يمكنني ان اقول وبشكل قاطع
بانشدار اوغلو يحتل المرتبه الاولى في
السباق الرئاسي وبخصوص النيابه البرلمانيه
لا يمكنني ان اقول نفس الشيء لوجود بنيه
مختلطه طبعا في كلا الطرفين والاحظ ان
النواب لا يحظون بدعم جماهري بشكل كبير
وهذه مشكله في هذا الخصوص لذا لا يمكنني
ان اتكهن بشان النتائج البرلمانيه لكن
بخصوص كليتشودار اوغلو فهو في المرتبه
الاولى من الدوره الاولى او الثانيه تقصد
بخصوص
يعني لا ادري قد يفوز في الجوله الاولى
ولست في موقف يمكنني من قول ذلك بشكل قاطع
ذلك عندما ننظر الى استطلاعات الراي نجد
ان النتائج تتراوح بين واحد وخمسين و52
و46 و45
وكانه يتاخر الى الجوله الثانيه
حتى لو فاز من الجوله الاولى او من الجوله
الثانيه البعض وحتى لو فزتم بالبرلمان
البعض يتوقع وضعا صعبا ستعيشونه مع معارضه
قاسيه وقويه جدا ومع امكانيه خرق
التحالفات التي قمتم بها لانه الكل سيطالب
بامتيازاته بعد الفوز اليس كذلك
بدايه دعني اقول اننا نطمح الى شيء واحد
الا وهو اننا نعد بنظام جيد لا شخص جيد
فالعالم في طور اخر فعندما تؤسسون نظاما
جيدا ستجد الاحزاب السياسيه الست مكانا
لنفسها داخل النظام بكل اريحيه نحن نعد
بالديمقراطيه في تركيا نعد بالحريات نعد
بنظام لا يشعر الانسان في ظله باي اضطهاد
ويعبر عن نفسه بكل حريه يستطيع فيه ان
يحاسب مصير ضرائ وثمه لا ثقل لاي معارضه
برلمانيه في ظل هذا النظام الذي ارساه
اردوغان بارلمان
قلتم انكم واثقون من قاعدتكم الانتخابيه
ولكن البعض يذهب الى ان شريحه من القوميين
قد لا تصوت لكم بعد دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكليتش دار اوغلو وقد لا تصوت
لك ربما خاصه من جماعه حزب الجيد او الخير
بزعامه ميرا الاكشنر وبعض القوميين في حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كذلك ما رايك
في الوقت الراهن حول ترشح كليتشار اوغلو
للرئاسه مع اي زعيم من شركائنا في التحالف
سواء مع السيده ميرال اكشنار او غيرها
يتغير الظروف بعد الانتخابات وهذه من
موجبات السياسه والاعتراض على ذلك غير ان
الاحزاب السته في التحالف الامه اليوم
عازمه على تغيير هذا النظام
قلت في المستقبل ربما يصبح هناك مشاكل اذا
انتم متخوفون مما يمكن ان تقدم عليه من
سياسات زعيمه حزب الجيد او الخير الى
ميرال الاكشنر بما انه كان لها اراء
مناهضه بعض الشيء قبل ان تقبل بترشيح كلتش
دار اوغلو يعني ابدا لا يمكن ان تحدث اي
مشكله قبل هذه الانتخابات اما بعد
الانتخابات فقد يحدث باعتبار اننا احزاب
سياسيه مختلفه ولا شيء يلزم هذه الاحزاب
على مواصله التحالفاتها بشكل ابدي وفي
الحصيله بعد تغيير هذا النظام سيذهب كل
حزب بحال سبيله هل قراءتكم ان اصوات محرم
ان جاء ستذهب اليكم بشكل كامل ام انها
ستتشتت وفق بعض القراءات وهل صحيح بانه قد
يكون هناك صفقه ما تحت الطاوله بينكم
وبينه بدايه لا يوجد اي اتفاق سري
ولا يمكن التكهن بنسبه اصوات السيد محرم
انج لكن عندما ننظر الى استطاعات الراي
العام نجد انها بحدود واحد ونصف واثنين في
المئه طبعا لا يمكن التكهن بمصير هذه
الاصوات من الان ثم ان السيد ان جاء لم
يفصح بعد عن صالح من انسحب من السباق
الرئاسي ولكن كانت يعني غريبا اتهام للروس
يعني تسريب الفيديوهات الفاضحه لمحرم انجا
لماذا
طبعا لا يمكن الاتهام اي دوله لعدم معرفه
بماهيه البيانات والمعلومات التي بين يدي
لكن في الاونه الاخيره ندرك بان هناك
مؤامره تحاك على حزبنا وزعمنا
خارج مساله محرم انجا ولا يمكن لي ان احدد
مركز هذه المؤامره عدم وجود معطيات بين
يديك بولد
هل انتم متخوفون من تسريب من تنفيذ الوعيد
وتسريب تسجيلات على الاقل
حول لقاءاته المزعومه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
جمهوريه كلا لسنا متخوفين الكل يعلم بانه
لا يوجد لحزب الشعب الجمهوري اي اجنده
سريه طبعا سير الدعايات الانتخابيه على
اوتار المكائد يزعجنا لا شك
فيه يفهمكم حزب العداله والتنميه دائما في
خطاباته بالتبعيه للغرب بانكم يعني تريدون
ان
تيمموا وجه تركيا نحو امريكا واوروبا وان
تتخلوا عن كل السياسات التي قادها في
الفتره الاخيره للانفتاح شرقا اكثر كيف
تردون تركيا
مصطفى كمال سياسه التركيه تقوم على نحو
قول مصطفى كمال اتاتورك سلام في الوطن
سلام العالم نحن في حزب الشعب الجمهوري
لدينا مطالب في الانضمام الكامل الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ امد بعيد وفي الوقت
ذاته لا يمكننا التخلي عن العالم العربي
واعتقد ان لتركيا دورا كبيرا في ترسيخ
السلام والاخوه في العالم العربي كلنا
يعلم ما قام به اردوغان في العالم مع
القوى الامبرياليه في الفترات السابقه
سواء في القضيه العراقيه ام تلك
الاضطرابات التي اختلقها في شبه جزيره
العربيه او القضيه السوريه كل هذا نابع من
تعاون اردوغان مع امريكا نحن نريد ان ناتي
بعلاقاتنا مع العالم العربي الى مستوى
توطيد وتعزيز اواصر الاخوه
الاتهامات تصل الى حد ليس فقط التخوين
والعماله للغرب وانما ايضا التعاطي
والتعامل مع ارهابي وفقه منظوره هو وهنا
نتحدث عن تنظيم فتح الله جولان الذي يصفه
بالارهابي وعن تنظيم
حزب العمال الكردستاني اذا انتم يعني
متهمون من الجانبين بالتعامل مع ما يسميه
هو
بالارهابلون
طبعا
التي لا يثبت عليها شيء فعلاقه حزب
العداله والتنميه مع تنظيم
كعلاقه الدجاجه والبيض واتهامنا بذلك ليس
بمكانه وفيما يتعلق باتهامه ايانا
بالتعامل مع
يمكنكم فقط بالنظر الى تقارير اوسلو ان
تجدوا مدى الخيانات التي تورط بها هذا
النظام
ولكن حزب العمال الكردستاني
ما يوصف بجناحه السياسي يدعمكم او يدعم
بالاحرى تحديدا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وانتم تقولون الا تعامل معهم كيف ذلك
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي حزب سياسي تاسس قبل
32 سنه وحتى عام 2018 استخدم الناخب
الكردي المؤيد لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
اصواته لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه ولم
يقم الحزب في هذه الفتره بمسائله حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي عن علاقته بحزب العمال
الكردستاني ومتى بدات هذه المساءلات بدات
عام 2019 عندما ايد حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
اكرم امام اوجلو بينما انتخب الاكراد حزب
العداله والتنميه منذ عام
سياسيا يحصل على سبعه ملايين صوت ومن ثم
ياتي ويتهموه بالتواطئ مع الارهاب انه
يسيء لبلده
ولكنكم متهمون بما هو ابعد من ذلك فيما
يتعلق بنوع من انواع العنصريه ضد اللاجئين
الموجودين في بلادكم على اثر تعرض بلادهم
لحرب ماساويه وانتم ما فتئتم تطالبون
باعادتهم الى بلادهم كيف تردون على هذه
الجزئيه
الارث
اولا سيتبنى حزب الشعب الجمهوري دورا
كبيرا لاقرار السلام لا في سوريا فقط بل
في ربوع الشرق الاوسط كاملا حال وصوله الى
السلطه
واما عن عزمنا باعاده اخواننا اللاجئين
الى ديارهم فلن يكون ذلك قبل تعزيز السلام
سنلتقي بشار الاسد وقد دعونا قبل سنوات
الى ضروره اللقاء مع السيسي والان نشهد
كيف ان اردوغان يبذل جهودا دبلوماسيه
لاجراء لقاء مع السيسي والاسد وسيحقق حزب
الشعب الجمهوري ذلك بكل سهوله
نقطه الانفتاح والتحرر الان
انتم تلامون من المجتمع المحافظ ومن قاعده
حزب العداله والتنميه ومن قياداته لانكم
لا تراعون شريحه كبيره من المجتمع ومجتمع
كله دينه الاسلام تقريبا او باغلبيته من
خلال افكاركم التي تدعو الى الانفتاح
والتحرر وهدم كثير من القيم التي تربى
عليها المجتمع التركي كيف تتناولون هذه
النقطه
انا انحدر من اسره محافظه والمحافظه لا
تنحصر بحزب العداله والتنميه وسترون في
الايام القادمه اننا سنحصد اكثر اصواتنا
من الاوساط المحافظه
علامه تبني هذه القناعه بانه هناك قاعده
ها انا محافظ هل هناك من هو اشد مني
محافظه لا نسرق ولا نختلس ولا ننتهك
الحقوق
ومرجعيتنا رسول الله
المحافظه من شيامنا ولله الحمد
ولكن عندما نقول محافظ نقصد ربما شخصيات
قياديه في حزب العداله والتنميه على الاقل
مثل رجب طيب اردوغان احمد داوود اوغلو
الذي يعني انضم الى تحالفكم وغيرهم من
الشخصيات القياديه وليس من هو منتمن الى
حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعروف بانه يعني حزب
علماني وليس بالمعنى المحافظ المتدين وهذا
يعني اعتقد او كنت اعتقد بانه هو يعني فرز
واضح وعادل اليس كذلك يعني
لا بد لي ان اوضح مساله
ان العلمانيه والمحافظه ليست بظاهرتين
متصارعتين فقد ناضل قائدنا الكبير مصطفى
كمال اتاتورك كثيرا لارساء مبادئ
العلمانيه في العالم الاسلامي لا في تركيا
فقط بل في جميع دول العالم لان العلماني
في الوقت ذاته صون لقيا من المقدسه الان
انظر الى زعماء العالم الاسلامي وقادتهم
وقصورهم الفارهه واساليب حياتهم الباذخه
هذا لا ينبغي ان يكون وان كانوا اسسوا
دولهم على اسس دينيه لذلك العلمانيه
والمحافظه مبداان منسجمان ومتناغمان لا
متنافران
اي تركيا تريدون في حزب الشعب الجمهوري
نحن حزب سياسي وضمان لمن يريد ان يعبر عن
نفسه بحريه سواء كان محافظا ام غير محافظ
صاحب عقيده كان ام لا تركيا كان ام كرديا
ام عربيا واللاجئين الذين اضطرتهم الظروف
الى اللجوء الينا عشرون عاما مضت على حكم
حزب العداله والتنميه يعني والرئيس
اردوغان كيف تصفون تلك العشرين عاما التي
مرت على تركيا
منذ عام
1994 كان انذاك رئيسا للبلديه وانا كنت
عضوا في مجلس البلديه كان جيدا في السنوات
العشر الاولى من حكمه من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه والاداريه اما اليوم اقولها
بشكل قاطع وصريح انه جعل تواجه ازمه
اقتصاديه كبيره
شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا في هذه المقابله
الخاصه
مشاهدينا الكرام هكذا نكون ايضا قد وصلنا
الى ختام هذه المقابله الخاصه من اسطنبول
مع القيادي في حزب الشعب الجمهوري شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو
ثائقي لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات